direction Blois ou le pire a finalement
été évité la nuit dernière une fillette
de 4 ans est tombée du troisième étage
en pleine nuit c'est une voisine qui l'a
recueilli blessée et en pyjama sa mère
s'était absentée alors que la petite
fille dormait sur place on retrouve
Florent Clavel la fillette de 4 ans a
été retrouvée au pied de cet immeuble de
la rue Dumont d'Urville blessé mais bien
vivante il était un peu moins de 5
heures du matin ce dimanche c'est une
voisine qui a donné l'alerte une chance
pour la petite victime frigorifiée et
souffrant d'un traumatisme facial elle a
été immédiatement prise en charge par
les pompiers et hospitalisés à Tours je
vous propose d'écouter le témoignage de
la voisine qui a donné l'alerte
je me suis levée pour boire un coup et
j'ai ouvert un petit peu la fenêtre pour
prendre de l'air frais et donc
j'entendais quelqu'un pleurer et je me
suis dit on dirait c'est un enfant qui
pleure et je me suis dit bah j'y vais je
prends une couverture il fait super
froid dehors donc je suis sortie je suis
arrivée en courant et je l'ai vu par
terre allongé et quand elle s'est
retourné j'ai vu que son sa joue était
ouverte et elle était en train de
saigner et elle m'a dit je suis tombée
avant ça j'ai déjà joué un déjà à la
police pour lui prévenir qu'il y avait
un enfant dehors et elle me disait que
elle veut voir maman elle l'appelait sa
maman alors que s'est-il passé dans cet
immeuble d'une cité HLM de Blois selon
les premiers éléments de l'enquête la
fillette a chuté du troisième étage du
logement où elle habitait elle avait été
laissée seule par sa mère tandis que son
petit frère de quatre mois avait été
confié à une voisine la fillette aurait
ouvert la fenêtre au-dessus de son lit
aurait donc chuté placé en garde à vue
hier après-midi la mer partager d'une
trentaine d'années selon les voisins
étaient relâchés le père lui a également
été interpellé mais pour une plainte
déposée par la femme début janvier pour
violence conjugale selon le voisinage
les altercations sur fond d'alcool était
régulière une enquête préliminaire a été
ouverte et les enfants confiés à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance